We want to find the work of (x - 4) and (x + 7).
Let's try to write it as a triple square in normal shape.
This is just a modern way of naming the species,
in which we have some coefficient in front of the second degree member ax ^ 2
plus any coefficient b in front of the first degree member
plus a free member.
This is a normal type of square triple.
This is the kind in which we want to express this work
and I recommend pausing the video
and try to do it yourself.
Okay, now let's do it together.
The key in multiplying two two-
or, in fact, by multiplying any multiples,
is simply not to forget the distribution property,
which each of us knows at this stage well enough.
We can treat it as revealing the brackets
and multiplying (x -4) by x and 7.
We can say that this is the same thing
such as (x -4) by x
plus (x -4) at 7.
Let's write it.
(x-4) along x,
or we could write it as x in (x -4).
This is a multiplication of (x -4) by x
This here.
Plus 7 in (x -4).
By (x -4).
Note that all we've done is multiply by (-4).
We took this whole thing and multiplied it by every member here.
We multiplied x by (x -4)
and multiplied by 7 (x -4).
We now see that we have these
two separate members.
To simplify each of them, we simply need to multiply again,
we uncover the brackets again.
In this first we will have to multiply this blue x.
And here we have to multiply on this blue 7.
Let's do it.
Here we can say x by x is x ^ 2.
Here we have a minus,
so we can say -4 and it will be -4x.
And thus we get x 2 - 4x.
And then here we have 7 on x,
so this will be plus 7x.
And then we have 7 at -4,
which is -28.
And we're almost ready.
We can simplify it a little bit.
Here we have two first degree members.
If we have -4x and add to it 7x,
how much will it be?
Well these two articles together,
these two articles assembled together
will be (-4 + 7) x.
-4 plus 7.
(-4 + 7) x.
All I do here is to make it clear,
that I collect these two coefficients
and then we have all the other members.
We have x2.
x ^ 2 plus this and then we have ...
and then we have -28.
And we're in the final right!
This will be simplified to x ^ 2 ...
Now, -4 plus 7 is 3,
so this will be plus 3x.
Here's how those two members are simplified in the middle, up to 3h.
And then we have -28.
And so we're ready!
An interesting thing we can look at because it's the same ...
If we have to compare, A is one,
B is three and C is -28.
Interesting here is to follow the formula,
when we multiply these two two-fold.
Especially these two two-
where the coefficient in front of the x is one.
Note that I have x on x,
which in fact forms the member x ^ 2 here.
We have -4, let's write it in a new color.
We have -4 on ...
this is not another color.
We have -4 at 7,
which is -28.
And then how do we get this average member?
How do we get this 3x?
Well we had -4x plus 7x.
Or (-4 + 7) on x.
We had -4 + 7,
by x.
I hope you see some regularity here.
If you multiply two two-
where both the x coefficients of the members are units.
This will be x ^ 2.
And then the last member, the free member
will be the work of these two constants.
-4 and 7.
And then the first degree member here is here,
its coefficient will be the sum
of these two constants, -4 and 7.
Now you can use it
this formula if you exercise it.
It's just something that will help you
to multiply two members a little faster.
But it is extremely important
to understand where it comes from.
It is nothing more than
applying the distribution property twice.